في حديث خاص مع الجزيره يرسم طرف الصراع
في السودان رؤيتهما للمشهد الحالي البدايه
مع رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان
يحمل الرجل قوات الدعم السريع مسؤوليه
تفجر المعارك
ويتهمها باستهداف الدوله السودانيه
للاستيلاء عليها البرهان وفي مقابله خاصه
مع الجزيره قال ان تحرك الدعم السريع ياتي
على خلفيه منع توحيد القوات المسلحه واتهم
الدعم السريع بمحاوله تحويل الاتفاق
الايطالي لصالح قائده واعتبر ان الدعم
السريع ومن وصفهم بالاسلاميين المتطرفين
نظراء
اما قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميدتي سيدتهم البرهان بتنفيذ انقلاب في
السودان وبعدم الالتزام بالاتفاق الايطالي
ويؤكد في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره ان قوته
تقاتل دفاعا عن النفس حسب وصفه
بالنسبه له فان الهدف من هذه العمليه
العسكريه هو التخلص من البرهان وايداعه
السجن ووقف سيطره من وصفهم بالاسلاميين
على القرار في الجيش لا يقف التراشق
الكلامي عند هذا الحد يتعدى الى اتهام كل
طرف للاخر بالتعاون مع قوى خارجيه يتحدث
البرهان عن معلومات تفيد بان دولا لم
يسميها تحاول التدخل في الشان السوداني
ويؤكد ايضا ان الجيش لا يسمح بوصول اي دعم
خارجي للطرف الاخر وينفي بشكل قاطع تسلم
دعم من اي دوله خارجيه
بدوره يصف حميدتي غريمه البرهان بانه مجرد
مستخدم لدى اخرين وانه يفتقد للقدره على
اتخاذ القرارات وينفي تسلم اي مساعدات
خارجيه وايضا اي علاقه بين قوته وميليشيا
فاكرر ومع تصاعد المواقف يبقى السؤال ما
هو الحل كما يراه كل طرف بالنسبه للبرهان
فان حديث السياسه مع قوات الدعم السريع لم
يعد ممكنا فاي تفاوض مع من وصفهم
بالخارجين عن القانون والمتمردين ليس
مقبولا لا يقفل البرهان باب الحوار نهائيا
لكنه يقول ان التفاوض ممكن مع من لم يتورط
في القتال من قاده الدعم السريع اما
بالنسبه لحميدتي فان الحل الوحيد للازمه
يتلخص في تسليم البرهان للعداله كما يقول
[موسيقى]